you did stand-up when you were in med
school yeah and I was curious like what
kind of stand-up were you doing what
you're doing in your stand-up bad it was
really bad it was really very hacky kind
of like I I don't I would do like kind
of I mean I one of my first jokes was
like it was it was it was Johnny Carson
in Korean really bad hacky what
happening you were doing an impression
of giannios like 20 years ago yeah so
Johnny Carson the Greg the great legend
and you were doing hitting a curry
if he was in if he was in Korean and
talking about like did this how dated oh
well it was like John Wayne Bobbitt
right the the person whose wife Loreena
had cut off his member yeah that was a
monologue joke I was doing 24 years ago
literally kids look it up on the
Internet ha ha ha it was asleep she
chopped off his thing yeah put it back
on but backwards it's great yeah but
that was my first stand-up joke and not
making this up I literally would it was
so it was so bad that it was like in is
ina onion ha Shaniqua that's a really
good card John Wayne Bobbitt John G
table saw how do you dumb I like um sir
[Applause]
you